نتنياهو الإسرائيلي والملك البحريني الملك حمد آل
خليفة أعرب كلا الزعيمين
عن تعازيهما
وكذلك للشعب الأمريكي في هذا
الحدث المأساوي للغاية الذي
وقع في 11 سبتمبر
وأه عني ذلك كثيرًا أريد أن
أشكرهم على عدم وجود
رد أقوى على
الكراهية التي ولدت 9 11 ثم
الاتفاق الذي نحن على وشك إخباركم به
سوف تسمع شيئًا اليوم أعتقد أنه
مهم جدًا ليس فقط
للشرق الأوسط ولكن
للعالم بروح السلام والتعاون على
حد سواء  يتفق القادة أيضًا على أن البحرين
ستطبع علاقاتها الدبلوماسية بشكل كامل
مع إسرائيل ،
وأنهم سيتبادلون السفارات
ويبدأ السفراء رحلات جوية مباشرة بين
بلدانهم ويطلقون مبادرات تعاون
عبر
مجموعة واسعة من القطاعات بما في ذلك
تكنولوجيا الأعمال الصحية والتعليم
والأمن والزراعة. إنه يوم تاريخي حقًا
هناك  كانت اتفاقيتا سلام مع
إسرائيل
في آخر 72 عامًا ، وهذا هو
الآن  اتفاقية السلام econd التي
أعلناها في الشهر الماضي
وآمل جدًا أن يكون هناك
المزيد لمتابعة.
يمكنني أن أخبرك أن هناك
حماسًا هائلاً نيابة عن الدول الأخرى
للانضمام أيضًا ونعتقد أنه في
النهاية ستنضم معظم الدول
وسيكون لديك الفلسطينيون
في وضع جيد جدًا
يريدون القدوم إليه ، ويرغبون في القدوم
لأن جميع أصدقائهم موجودون ولكن